c'est un instant solennel et symbolique
pour ces vignerons
rassemblés dans l'église de sancerre
sous la bannière de leur confrérie ils
rendent hommage à saint vincent leurs
patrons spirituel
un vin de qualité une belle cuvée 2021
les vignerons ne demande que ça l'un
d'eux a le privilège de voir sa
production bénie par le prêtre
[Musique]
place ensuite à la mise en perce du
tonneau
et à la dégustation il a du nez toujours
avec modération bien sûr
les frétillants il est bien il est très
bon
il ya déjà la fraîcheur de la saison
frais mais très fruité la douceur je
pense que c'est un millésime qui va
plaire
aux amateurs
plus qu'une cérémonie religieuse le
rassemblement incarne la solidarité
entre vignerons de chaque confrérie
c'est des valeurs de labeur c'est des
valeurs ancestrales aussi puisque saint
vincent remonte à quelques siècles en
arrière etc des valeurs de partage entre
vignerons entre régions aussi quand un
vigneron est malade quand à lyon et dans
le besoin et blesser les autres
vignerons peuvent venir l'aider dans les
vignes dans les travaux de la vigne
notamment
toute la confrérie espèrent désormais
une année viticole fructueuse épargné
par les aléas climatiques